hello and welcome to this video I should
do that before starting but keep
forgetting that anyway let's play a
blitz cami against the doors played him
before you have two times okay so we're
in a keto Gurunath out 96 is not very
common and I'm not really familiar
after same experimenting a little bit
with those opening lines him yeah this
is not the kind of thing that looks
extremely natural with the night coming
to a five but that is what they usually
do him
you have maybe a quicker route d1
Blackwell yeah to play this I guess so
yeah I think I've seen something like
that
and I think it had something like that
also on the board ones in the Dutch
league it's a long time ago
okay
we should to h3 maybe how do we develop
this him
you
t5 is probably leading nowhere
to take and play night before I guess
that's not
very promising
yeah I don't know just develop
I would like to play Roxy one
and finally have my rook opposed to the
black queen like group c1 move my queen
than 95 something like that yeah this is
what I actually hoped for
is killing off his his own Bishop there
on g7
okay so a different kind of approach she
wants to play with 94 hem okay yeah so
I'm going to play for the d5 square
myself now 95
if he goes 94 I have 97
and then check on g4 all right yeah so I
can do that first I of course I have to
watch
or the clock
some interesting ideas oh okay six did
not think about them at all
okay okay I don't have I don't have
critics is-6 yam that leads nowhere
leads to yeah equality Quincy 697 I
would absolutely like to play Bishop f1
you
hmm cannot
very slow he cannot claim
for because of 97 the whole time and I
mean this move was designed to make
Queen moves more difficult 26s 97 Queen
d7 might be playable but I have no I
have six that is I guess irritating
enough
covering it seven yeah makes our sense
but the Queen still has no move Sam
still has no moose now b44 be five maybe
94 is an interesting move now
I think I can take it 94 bishop d1 night
b5 maybe he's got Bishop c4 what a wacky
move a bishop see - I mean 94 takes
Bishop takes Knight d5 Bishop c2 is
strange strange but possible anyway it's
not such a big deal this 94 I'm on I'm
on that square quite a bit now c1 and I
still have 97 so where is the queen
going to d8
yeah
97's capture on f3 okay
anyway let's play replace loans
you
anything here
maybe I maybe I had to rush it but me no
hits
still
with 13 seconds you need to decide on on
something
maybe I had 97 already in 97 takes
shakes
maybe I could've played that
you
oh wow it just plays a crazy move to
irritate me
oh okay
but for seconds oh my god
and my position is very good actually
at 6 seconds is not really really a lot
of time
now it's e7 or I've got also and that's
his 7th
so Big Fork
it's a shaky game it
minutes sometimes a bit critical not yet
awake
don't do anything important that if I'm
out of bed for such a short span of time
I never drive for example its but then
playing chess is kind of difficult
sometimes when you have you're still a
little bit
wait let him
that is maybe not the best solution but
it's a simple solution
[Music]
well not not said simple yet you
good the pawn man cannot cope we should
be fun fortunately hmm yeah not easy at
all
nice got Bishop b5 stuff bishop d5 I can
take Mia I stumbled into that and he can
maybe he could have captured maybe on g2
but okay since nine seconds
d5 or p5 well sometimes oh they didn't
see that one
yeah here the time will be a problem oh
oh it's not just a time
now kingi three-year is threatening
checkmate
bloody murder I have known I wanted
silly yogic game I'm losing this game
I was shoot I mean I know it's the draw
technically I had a v-8 rookie true
all right such as such a cine game yeah
yeah it's it's it's basically I mean
it's impossible to defend us
with the with the increment and it's not
even helpful that I have their pawn it's
actually a big issue
should be d3 was a problem really big
problem it makes it wrong it is very
silly the whole whole game was alia
should win of course but again I wasn't
quite yet yet awake in particular like
here I should definitely win this is
like okay plus 10 plus 10 here Bishop
takes you six kills but this is also
completely winning so with this this why
didn't I wouldn't you okay I mean I had
no time but still yeah it was hard to
slow anyway I think this is probably a
relatively normal position looks kind of
kind of standard okay he played a five
and then this move yeah and here I've
held that playing for d5 was an
interesting idea the engine wants to
play Knight b5 but let's have a look
there there are many interesting
tactical ideas here 95 red rook a six
not so what I expected to happen but
then move I didn't really have on the
radar this does not work
yeah I can I wanted to play um I
actually didn't want it to go to play 97
but this is actually stronger yeah of
course a this is just stronger yeah okay
let's not play okay okay a six Queen d3
and rook e8 I went before 94 yeah and I
hacking on DC one of course just
unpinned ah and I miss many things I
have again make it was not really awake
yet a three is actually correct and then
he played the crazy move f5 which is
just like irritating me with no time it
makes sense I mean it is very obviously
very bad
I mean you f5 you don't really know it's
bad but
um it was very irritating okay I took it
Ruki one young and it's I mean it must
be very bad because they look at this
position but unprotected looks at a pawn
forks bad King and so on it's just it's
a terrible position but again I had
absolutely no time and this is sick
really putting it mean hmmmm young and
f4 was even stronger but yeah and there
were many ways here to kill him off
Bishop three sixes it's very powerful of
course I'm covering this and black
cannot take on g6 which means there is
no move actually okay so I try to yeah
play a simple moves but and now I need
some precision to to win Luke t6 is
given by the comp yeah I mean this is a
desirable move what I did not really see
is that I have f4 hem and this is
stopping the main threat and that means
I'm probably winning in the pansori this
pawn and probably the game oh I didn't
didn't see that and now it gets a bit
problematic
okay Luke t6 okay I didn't see that I
check here I'm still on that
so let us the next move that would win
and now as I didn't see it this is now
probably a draw I mean he's so active
and looks at this all the time that I
probably cannot win I mean I still tried
but it's um it was probably a bit more
than I should have tried
t6 again was possible and now after g5
its it's impossible to win absolutely
impossible and therefore is probably
mistake yeah there's some some way to
exploit it Bishop g5
I thought takes King g7 and then yeah I
have to give this up like and then maybe
you can draw it well I'm not sure
they're probably not yeah it was a very
shaky part of the game on him again that
that should be a draw
five is very stupid it's a very stupid
move but I was in while I was a bit too
hectic I think giving inviting the king
and then would be for I also didn't play
and now I know I'm in in big trouble I
actually still this is losing do YouTube
should be to okay okay that was a
terrible game
what a terrible game yeah I mean III
didn't want to do that but Bishop
everyone seems to hold yeah I always
have the checks here so that I will hold
but okay so Bishop e2 was possible but
that also losses of course yeah this was
something that I felt was an idea but he
didn't do that yeah and now I think
probably it's switching back and forth
from draw to win quite often because um
I was basically making yeah I have to
play quickly here here picking C three
wins and Bishop c4 wins he didn't play
that it was kind of obvious now it's
made he didn't do it somehow okay I can
do this because it was not so obvious
but it failed right let's say let's put
it like that and now he's coming this
way
yeah I'm so rock group iam Luke a8
yeah this is still made so have to go
here and then he asked the check and
wins and after that should be a draw but
I might so be losing here
rookie aid I have to play okay
yeah whatever I just made meat moves and
hope for the best
hey I should probably I should almost
win this yeah like after he played this
Venky f5 move but I know I was kind of
falling asleep at no time at all ok guys
thanks for watching